There are a couple of different
ways to let your mobile app know
which analytics account to use.
You can do it programmatically, or
you can use an xml configuration file.
In this lesson,
we're going to use an xml file to
configure our analytics tracker.
You'll need to create a new xml
file in the res xml folder.
Go to res choose New >
Android Resource Directory.
The name of the directory is xml.
Now that you've got your xml folder,
you create a new resource file.
You can call the file what you like.
I suggest something like track_app.xml
You'll need to make sure that
the root element is resources.
The most important thing to put
in the analytics config file
is the analytics account id.
Do that by adding a string
resource that has the name
ga_trackingId and
the value is your analytics id.
And remember that you can get your cam
id from the analytics admin dashboard.
But to start within our app, we're
going to enable automatic tracking, so
you'll need to add the string
resource ga_autoActivityTracking
to the config file.
The autoActivityTracking
needs to be set to true.
This is the minimum you need in
your tracking config file, but
I strongly recommend you
also configure screen names